Russia is using its words and its
actions to send a warning to the US
tonight Moscow has sent a warship to
Cuba and says the US weapons buildup in
Europe could spark a repeat of one of
the most dangerous conflicts of the Cold
War national security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin has the story tonight
from the Pentagon the new
state-of-the-art Russian warship
received a warm welcome after pulling
into Havana Harbor just 90 miles from
Florida occupying a berth which until a
recent travel ban was filled by American
tourists cruise ships this is a clear
show of force by by Russia Russia's
Deputy Foreign Minister warned of a new
Cuban Missile Crisis if the u.s. chooses
to deploy missiles back to Europe after
the Trump administration said it plans
to pull out of a landmark nuclear arms
treaty quote we could find ourselves in
a situation where we have a rocket
crisis close not just to the crisis of
the 1980s but close to the Caribbean
crisis the Russians are basically
launching a big propaganda campaign at
this at this time claiming that the
United States is acting in a provocative
fashion which is simply not true the
arrival in Havana not as menacing as
this encounter weeks ago in the western
Pacific
when a Russian destroyer harassed the
USS Chancellorsville nearly colliding
forcing the American warship to alter
course earlier this month Moscow says
one of its fighter jets intercepted a
USB 52 bomber in the Black Sea one of
many increasingly aggressive encounters
between the two Cold War foes back in
Havana the arrival of the Admiral
Gorshkov a new class of Russian frigate
armed with cruise missiles signals
Russia's intention to project power
Russia's show-and-tell comes in the wake
of a 10,000 NATO troop month-long war
game exercise on Russia's doorstep in
the Baltic Sea involving 50 allied
warships and as the Pentagon announced
plans to add new low yield nuclear
weapons to ballistic missile submarines
a response to Russia's threat to use
limited nuclear weapons on the
battlefield president Trump's new acting
defense secretary mark s
floow2 NATO headquarters today his
second day on the job for meetings about
Russia and to build an alliance against
Iran
Brett Jennifer Griffin at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you